quand j'étais enfant je faisais un rêve
un cauchemar en fait je me trouve dans
un un étroit passage et il fait noir et
j'ouvre une sorte de trappe elle est là
et elle est prisonnière
car alice charisme ma mère est morte il
ya quelques jours elle a laissé sa au
milieu du lit je crois qu'elle voulait
que je le trouve bien allons la balle
vos vivier ici quand carriço elle a été
enlevée on ne veut pas de vous ici
c'est une drôle de vie bénite beaucoup
de caractère mais caris howell a été
détenu dans cette maison est ce que vous
croyez que que les morts peuvent
communiquer avec nous
qui est là
je comprends pas ce qui m'arrive
est ce que je suis en train de devenir
folle si je les têtes il me le dirait
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît je peux rentrer chez moi
non